[Music]
we're very excited miss April O'Neill I
am so excited to be here we're really
excited we're presenting today
[Applause]
no I was just getting in the spirit of
everything getting people excited for
rise of the teenager knows the show well
I really am fond of renowned Renaissance
man Leonardo DiCaprio
so hence why I'm here for the sake of
Leonardo is this just the beginning of
the shenanigans as host tonight I don't
know what you're talking I'm hosting
tonight my god I gotta get going I'm
hosting right here right now
unbelievable so that's our cast so
there's there's some excitement about
this show listen
so tell me about it and who everyone
plays hi my name is Ben Schwartz I play
Leonardo Omar Miller I play Raphael Josh
Brent SR Josh Brener and I play
Donatello Brandon Michael Smith oh yes
sorry cat me first sorry cat
Brandon Michael Smith I play
Michelangelo you're surrounded by
gentlemen on this show how are you
keeping them they're animals they're
animals
no they're there honestly they're
honestly really really funny and amazing
and I'm just like you know it's it's
great cuz we're playing a cartoon but I
really like I really wish I had like
physical human
real-life scenes with these guys cuz
they're like this hey so and you know
what I think that might happen you know
live right now potentially
[Music]
[Applause]